outside of the YouTube channel the
reason why I feel like this was already
kind of in the works because I know you
A.D and I know you are not the most
sensitive guy to get that pissed off
about someone saying that you had the
same four jokes I said oh this was the
perfect Catalyst to be like we out
because there's no way my guy A.D who I
could bust balls with all the [__]
time gets that offended by hearing that
someone thought he had the same four
jokes that he's like I quit [__] y'all
we out it was it was more than just the
the four jokes there was a ton of [__]
first there's a ton of [__] behind the
scenes but I think the narrative is like
that was like the the thing that you
were like I'm out it was the confiding
in somebody
that I feel like
yeah you could talk among colleagues and
stuff like that because he could have
told t-rell that it's when it's brought
to my attention and you talk to me tell
me how you honestly feel because if to
me if you talk behind my back you'll
talk behind my back about all types of
[__] right so I don't know what the [__]
it really is at the end of the day and
it was like also this was it the same
week that the Richard Spencer thing and
I was saying the timing of everything
was just weird it was like I call you
out for this now this week is and that's
one thing people are understanding we're
like you guys are not friends it's
business but I'm like if you leading the
conversation is hey for our friendship
to remain I think you should come do
this over here so I'm like I'm looking
at it on some friendship he's wording it
as friend like I'm putting my my whole
life into this this company for sure you
know what I'm saying so I'm like I just
feel like it should have been handled a
lot differently because I could take hey
you don't want me over here all right
cool I'll come do this over here we can
continue the business going but you know
after hearing everything that transpired
and even after we even made our exit I'm
like oh yeah we made the right decision
yeah it felt like a very you know
stressful place to be around
I told uh my boy out he was like yo you
wouldn't you wouldn't be on no jumper I
was like [__] no I want no part of that
toxic ass but it wasn't stressful for us
when we came in no no because you guys
we like the crowd favorite you know and
you guys kind of kicked off I feel like
you guys literally kicked off the
current business model over there yeah
100 like without you there's no him and
without you there's no like random shows
that Adam isn't necessarily on camera we
just bought like you know a sense of
team and camaraderie to the building
that wasn't there at first because
before that it was just strictly due to
pod ain't no business and stuff like
that and I was like all for teamwork and
when T rail came he's like a real
overthinker he's like look we got to be
a team so everything was just
reinforcing that's how he was moving you
know he'll come into office and he'll
crack jokes with everybody like that's
what make the [__] fun we're sitting
there saying [__] to each other and it
was just all love and [__] too so you
know I also think Tyrell you're like a
natural bro I think I told you
the interview you did with J Stone I
think you did one with mozzie I was just
like those are like some of the like the
best interviews with mozzie and jaystone
had ever seen and this is something
you're new like you're not like
necessarily interviewing folks like you
know what I mean but I just thought well
Jason I did by myself mozzie we did and
and the collective we did on the Pod but
still because it was like a big moment
yeah yeah yeah you know what I'm saying
yeah two like some of those moments too
like are key for me you know like
especially when you interviewing
somebody and they like barely talking
they saying one word or you say
something they don't like and they look
at you it's just like how you get out
that [__] conversation like that but
I study [__] like you you know
what I'm saying like Adam I study I
study y'all man because you guys are
like super like great at this [__] like
I'm studying [__] writing [__] down I'm
trying to re-memorize and you
[__] just hop on the mic like
hey what's going on and just you know
super conversationalism but yeah man I
mean that [__] taught me a lot over
there I [__] with it man I'm saying I
appreciate everything that I got from it
you know I'm saying I appreciate Adam
everything he you know I'm saying he
gave me you know I'm saying everything
he taught me
um from here on out but you know we got
to move on we had to do what we had to
do I mean the same four joke [__] was
just like whatever it was just like
icing on the cake from just built up
[__] you know yes I would do know it
said which I totally you know yeah like
he's just that type of [__] and I had we
all had to hold do no down do you know I
was like bro I'm gonna do you know being
willing to get up he was like I'm only
here for y'all I put mornings on power
106. yes but you know what like but it's
just I'm like you know don't do it right
now we all got to stick together hold it
down for me you know what I'm saying hey
we I really had to hold you know down
and then this was just like as soon as
that [__] happened to A.D it wasn't it
wasn't me I couldn't tell doing them
like hey like hold it down some more
like it's out like [__] this is out I'm
cool on this [__] like so we just had to
make that move and you know it's all
good like you know what I'm saying I
don't know but he a cool [__] you know
what I'm saying you know some of the
decisions he make as far as business or
whatever the case may be might not be on
point you feel me like you know and it's
just you know it's it's a learning curve
for every [__] body yeah I think it's
a learning curve for him too because I
feel like he's kind of always done [__]
where it's like just him and recording
and editing and like to like bring in
all these personalities and like you
know he's never really signed people
so I think that like there's that
narrative where he was like well in
hindsight maybe I should have signed him
this line and that I I don't know if
y'all saw me on the show oh I was
watching and I was like well if you
enter enter you know encourage them to
to go and do their own thing
like wouldn't that be like with the idea
that they might do very well and that's
and that was where I was that's another
reason why I'm looking at it a little
differently too because it's like if you
pushing us to do these things
and we reach in certain Heights to me it
made you look good right like I'm a boss
that put on these other bosses and put
them in a position not like oh we on
competition for each other and I feel
that's when the comments and uh these
outside narratives keep coming out
instead of really looking at who the
people are right you know what I'm
saying because we can get into it I can
get into him but I can talk to him I
don't have to be like hey bro [__] or
tell somebody something bad about him
and keep doing that and me and Adam we
didn't bumped his a million times right
but every time I'm saying hey bro you my
brother I'm looking at like a brother
right you're my brother if you wrong I'm
gonna tell you you wrong if I'm wrong
tell me I'm wrong it's a revolving door
it's not one-sided and a lot of times
like I know for me personally I know it
just felt one-sided it's like yeah you
could tell us when we wrong but when
you're wrong it's like up I ain't got to
say no it's not I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm like bro it
don't work like that I mean I think you
know communication and common sense it
didn't play a big part in this [__] I'm
saying like communication should have
been on an all-time high you know what
I'm saying it then common sense just get
up in there especially if you're on the
business level and you thinking and put
a little sprinkle a little friendship in
there let me get in there man these
dudes is doing their thing I see him
getting hot let me go off from some
before somebody else uh uh offering
something and let me see what that looks
like you know what I'm saying let me let
me go entertain this let me see what
this looks like and we'll be good we
didn't necessarily have to be on your
platform but it just in a perfect world
if I was to do it and I rewind it I'll
go back you know I'm saying let me sign
these guys for a year whatever keep
doing you you know I'm saying I'll take
my percentage whatever you're doing you
know I'm saying tours merch whatever the
case may be I was open to whatever you
know I'm saying I was open to whatever
anybody any deal anybody had you know
what I'm saying as soon as I began or
you know saying just leading into it
after a couple months but it's all good
man you know I'm saying it's just
business experiences that people
probably have never experienced yeah I
think that's really what it is right
it's like that's it dog it's like the
first time you go through something like
that it's like well in hindsight but at
the same time you got to kind of have
the business Acumen to be like well [__]
it's pretty obvious this is gonna this
is getting huge my Common Sense level
come on like maybe I should call a
meeting with the boys and yeah but like
when he said I don't know Joe [__] and
he was like they were enthusiastic sick
right but I didn't know they were that
enthusiastic at that point it's like
that line hurt me right now essentially
like that was like
they were gonna do good but I didn't
know they're gonna do that good like
yeah
yeah it still came like okay you guys
are doing good my bad let's try to see
right let's try to see instead of hey
guys I didn't realize this was gonna
happen you know and we would have did it
instead of you you still push this to
the side hold up all of this stuff is
still new right like we're looking at
this and like I mean you just celebrated
a year yeah you're not out of year yet
are you nah I'm at barely six months
crazy
yeah it's wild cool you guys have been
killing so for the new channel obviously
your guys's
um streams on each other's on your own
respective channels are really big
um it's gonna be is it gonna be
streaming [__] or is it gonna
essentially be everything just like you
guys are getting the space we're gonna
have streaming stuff over there we're
gonna have original content any ideas
that come to mind we're gonna be signing
Talent we're gonna be doing everything
we're supposed to do yeah but we also
gonna be taking our [__] time too
we're not going to be sitting out here
rushing just throwing [__] on camera
and just doing anything you know what
I'm saying like we'll take our time with
what we got right now and then we'll
just add gradually and then you'll just
see the growth and the evolution and
everything like and it's no need for us
to go in here and rush but we definitely
gonna come with it you know what I'm
saying because we you know we learn from
the best and just looking around you
feel me and having that free spirit and
free mind to go out and try to try new
[__] and you know and have it work like
we've seen the ins and out of all of
that [__] and that's just that was a
great experience in itself though so we
we got the sauce you know what I'm
saying and we just gonna implement it I
definitely think y'all had the sauce in
that building like y'all kind of brought
the flavor over there you know what I'm
saying like Michelle brought the
substance I feel like you can correct me
if I'm wrong but it felt like a lot of
artists had stopped like wanting to go
over there but it kind of felt like
because you were there they would still
go over there is that is that safe to
say yeah I fought hard like I'm telling
people like bro come [__] me man
listen I don't want to come over man
that's for me yeah it's a good look for
me and then you get certain individuals
that's coming through them doors and
upon using his resources he's been
trying to get you over there for almost
two years he's like ah you know what I'm
saying so you ain't doing no interviews
right now [__] no [__] [__]
playing golf
he's Rich come where [__] no hell I'm
at the Calabasas Country Club yeah no
but like you know I go to the club and
the artists be like bro they watching it
right they just like oh I don't want to
be involved with their platform and then
you know certain people like Wiz come
through harm
there's certain individuals like okay we
made it to where it was it was cool and
I feel like it got this identity back as
far as for a sec and then the identity
became all the drama man yeah how do you
guys prevent that same [__] from
happening
with your well [__] there's a lot of
drama I say we're not doing a good job
cause your [__] happened I mean but you
know
initially when drama happens it's it's
not on us you know I'm saying that it's
not our job to post clips and post the
videos and go hard with it like we're
not in control of that so if drama
happens and if you putting it out that
has nothing to do with us you know I'm
saying it can stay internally it can
stay in-house but if you choose to put
it out as a platform as a company that's
on you you know what I'm saying we
didn't ask nobody to do that we don't
control the clip channel the main
channel the Instagram we're not for sure
any of that [__] so who's really
controlling the narrative you know what
I'm saying like who's controlling what's
going on and what you guys see as far as
the drama and that really was like no on
camera drama like our pod at the end of
the day has never beefed or argued not
one [__] time you know what I'm
saying in the other part that left uh
which was disconnected they've never had
any drama at all either so all that
other [__] was just [__] that didn't
have anything to do with us and we'll
just speak on it you know what I'm
saying so those clips will arrive from
that [__] you know what I'm saying and
videos are right from that [__] but
still like we wasn't in control of
putting that out so we y'all written and
the people really can't blame us for
that [__] so no you know what I'm saying
and two is you you can't win for lose
because if you don't speak about it oh
you're scared you ain't speaking about
it or you're a PC and when you do speak
about it oh you're a messy you shouldn't
do that so it's like people don't know
what they want